[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and if you have any Bible
questions tonight we'd invite you to
give us a call we have several lines
open right now give us a call and you
have a good chance of getting your
question on tonight's program the phone
number 800 god says one more time that's
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven would you like to hear an
amazing fact scientists from Italy have
now enabled spiders to spin webs that
can hold the weight of a human according
to The Sydney Morning Herald a team from
the University of Toronto added graphene
and carbon nanotubes to a spiders
drinking water to see what would happen
graphene is a wonder material having
carbon atoms that are similar to
graphite in charcoal it's the strongest
material that's ever been tested
still it was a wild guess to see what
would happen if it was fed to spiders
after drinking the enhanced water the
graphene particles were transferred into
the spider silk producing a webbing that
is five times stronger than normal that
makes this spider silk as strong as pure
carbon fibers and bulletproof Kevlar
people have farmed silkworms for
millennia to produce silk baby spiders
are next these spiders might soon be
enlisted to help manufacture super rope
cables and possibly even parachutes you
know the Bible tells us there was a man
who could break even the strongest ropes
stay with his friends were going to
learn more on this edition of Bible
answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
that's one eight hundred four sixty
three seventy to ninety seven now let's
join our host pastor Doug Batchelor and
our co-host pastors Jean Ross lines are
open if you have a Bible question give
us a call right now 877-562-6019 the
program with prayer dear father in
heaven we thank you that we have this
opportunity once again to open up your
word and study together and through
these airwaves Lord we pray that the
Scriptures will become clear and
understanding that we have growing an
understanding of truth for we ask this
in Jesus name Amen amen
Oh pastor like you open the program
talking about an incredibly strong
material that comes from a rather small
animal despite end though you know we've
known for a long time that the silk the
spider silk used for the web is
remarkably strong as it relates to the
size obviously of the spider and yet
they've been able to come up with a
ingenious way of strengthening that silk
in sort of mass producing it at some
point where they could use it in all
kinds of things yeah and you know what I
didn't research and I wish I'd found out
more what kind of spiders did they use
because I just know from personal
experience that for instance a black
widow spider web is much stronger and
you've been with me before I got a
hanger and I've killed hundreds
literally hundreds of black widows it
doesn't love it there and I can always
tell when I see a web when I brush it
away if it was a black widow
ever if it was some other spider because
they're really tough and if a boy if
they actually fed this graphene to a
black widow I don't know if they know
that yeah and then it's five times
stronger well that'd be that'd be pretty
tough stuff but you know the bible does
talk about a man that they tied up
several times and they get fresh ropes
because when he first broke the ropes
they said well they must have been old
so they got brand new green hemp ropes
which are very strong ships used to use
them to hold them in place and it says
here in judges sixteen eleven Delilah
said our Samson's telling Delilah if
they bind me securely with new ropes
that have never been used then I'll
become weak and like other men therefore
Delilah took new ropes and bound him
with them while he was sleeping and she
woke him up and said Samson the
Philistines are upon you and he got up
and he broke them off his arms like
thread and that happened several times
when they tied him up he just broke one
time it says he broke the ropes like
they were flax in the fire yeah it's
super natural strength now what you
might be surprised if you know we've
learned about the scientific effects of
how to make spider silk really strong
I'll tell you how to make people really
strong the angel appeared the Samson's
mother before he was born and prescribed
that she and the child should not eat
unclean food or drink alcohol judges 13
verse four and five the angel said now
therefore please be careful he's telling
the mother who's gonna be pregnant not
to drink wine or strong drink and don't
eat anything unclean for behold you will
conceive and bear a son no razor will
come upon his head for the child will be
a Nazarite to God from the womb and he
will begin to deliver Israel out of the
hand of the Philistines and the same
thing the angel says Oh thousand years
later more than a thousand years later -
the parents are John the Baptist Luke
1:15 a lot of people this time of year
reading Luke chapter 1 for he will be
great in the sight of the Lord and will
drink neither wine or strong drink and
he will be filled with the Holy Spirit
even from his mother's womb now some
people wish they had the muscles of
Samson but the strength of John the
Baptist
was a spiritual strength filled with the
Holy Spirit and all of us can have that
it's interesting when used to drive by
the old the liquor stores it would say
wine in spirits but they were the wrong
kind of spirit the Bible says you want
the right kind of spirit then don't
drink the wrong kind of spirit and some
are surprised to learn the Bible says
you Christians should not drink alcohol
when it says wine in the Bible that
Jesus made it was not fermented it was
that's the same word they used for grape
juice you might want to know what the
Bible says on this subject friends we
have a free book that will be willing to
share with you the book is called the
Christian and alcohol on this a free
offer tonight if you'd like to call
we'll be happy to send it to you the
phone line this is our resource phone
line is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven you're gonna answer
the book the Christian and alcohol will
be able to send that to anybody who
calls an ass important subject what does
the Bible teach concerning alcohol in
the Christian one more time this is the
resource phone line 808 three five six
seven four seven just call and ask for
that free offer if you have a Bible
question a phone line here to the studio
is eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven again that's eight
hundred four sixty three seventy to
ninety seven can we go to our first
caller this evening we have dawn
listening in Florida Don welcome to
Bible answers life beau my question is
Jesus taught us to pray to the Father in
his name how do we then develop a
personal relationship with Jesus well
you're correct that not every time but
most of the time in the Bible were told
to address the father and keep this in
mind I know this may seem a little
confusing
but while Christ came into the world and
he is called the Son of God he is also
our Creator so in a sense he is also the
father you probably especially this time
of year people are remembering that
verse that says unto us a child is born
unto us a son is given and his name
shall be called wonderful counsellor the
mighty God the everlasting father
they're so in a sense Christ is also a
father to us that he's different from
God the Father but I'm saying he created
us so how do you develop a personal
relationship with Jesus separate from
the Father you're saying because you're
praying to the Father is that the
question yes if we're always praying to
the father how do we talk to Jesus now
remember Jesus said just before he
ascended to heaven
I think pastor Ross it was Philip that
asked the question show us the father
and jesus said have I been with you so
long and you don't know me he that has
seen me has seen the father so when you
talk to Christ
or the father in Christ's name God is
one he is one in the essence of who he
is with three persons so God is one
thing three individuals you know the
verse you're referring to is John
chapter 14 verse 9 Jesus says he who has
seen me has seen the father and you know
it's interesting past that I've
mentioning that Jesus said the Holy
Spirit would come he would not speak of
himself but he would speak of Christ and
reveal Christ Jesus came and he said I
don't speak of myself but I speak the
words which my father has given me and
I've come to reveal the father so the
spirit reveals the Son and the son
reveals the father and then the father
says two or three times this is my
beloved son hear him so they're always
in cross endorsing one another right and
so you'll find that the characteristics
of the father Don are identical to the
son because you know they're all love
and as you pray to the Father in
Christ's name Jesus hears those prayers
of spiritual prayer is and it's really
developing a relationship with the three
of the Godhead now also just after that
pass today you know we do have an
example in the Bible of Stephen who
actually prayed to Jesus mm-hmm this at
the time when he has been stoned so it's
not biblically wrong to pray to Jesus
although Christ has directed us to send
our praise to the father in his name but
we need to have a personal relationship
with Jesus and we can
now Peter actually prayed to Jesus when
he was drowning yeah Chris Christ was
still on earth they said Lord save me
quick prayer so you know if you'd like
don we have a book that we can send you
that talks about the trinity it's
actually a booklet it's very easy to
read it's got a lot of scripture and
good some good illustrations help us
understand this would you like a free
copy of that actually i've read it and
it's very good thank you very much I
appreciate it all right very good now
well I hope that I hope we helped a
little bit with your question you did
thank you very much all right thank you
for calling Don next one of the be
heavies can't listening from North
Carolina can't welcome to the program
this evening hey good evening pastors
even my question tonight was I was
looking at Hebrews four eight from the
King James do you want me to read it
sure okay for if Jesus had given them
rest then would he not afterward have
spoken of another day now I I understand
that you know the rest I believe the
rest is grace spoken of here and I
understand the truth of the Sabbath my
question is would he not after work
spoken of another day there speaking of
like reinstituting the Sabbath or is it
I just can you you know I can you kind
of just go over that series of verses
there and primarily verse four eight for
me kind of explain that to me I will and
you know you're you're asking a question
that's a good question because this is a
passage that's often misunderstood you
actually have to back up a little bit to
the verse just before that and in verse
seven it says again he designates a
certain day saying in David meaning in
the Psalms today after such a long time
and now he's quoting from Psalms
ninety-five seven and eight if you will
hear his voice don't harden your hearts
when it says there in verse 8 for if
Jesus had given them rest if you look in
the New King James or another version
the word Jesus in Hebrew is Yeshua or
Joshua it is not talking about Jesus
Christ they're our Savior it's talking
about Jesus
or Joshua if he had given them rest when
he brought them into the Promised Land
David would not later have spoken of
another day in the Psalms meaning the
ultimate rest that God is promising was
not just the promised land
it's a rest we find in Christ so here
the writer of Hebrews we believe is Paul
is he's to saying that the final rest
that David promised was not given to
them when they inherited the promised
land because Joshua brought the man and
David was already there and they're
still looking ahead to a rest so it was
another future risk that would come
which came through the son Christ so
that's what that often confuses people
is because it says Jesus there and Jesus
is actually just the Greek way of saying
Yeshua or Joshua
so it's speaking of the Old Testament
Joshua not Jesus oh yeah yeah okay that
makes more sense now all right hey thank
you very much appreciate your question
next caller that we have is Doug
listening in Michigan Doug welcome to
the program hello hi question hi my
question is about what Tom just did and
recognizing Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel I just wonder how that relates to
prophecy I'm glad you asked that
question I was hoping someone would
bring it up we even thought of opening
the program with an amazing fact about
that well first I'll tell you personally
I think it's something that needed to
happen I think most Americans recognize
that just because there are some Arab
countries that will diffuse to admit the
existence of Israel as a state and
that's why they of course they refuse to
admit the capital it doesn't mean that
we have to go along with that nonsense
Israel has been a state it's been voted
by the United Nations they've been
operating for 60 years 60 plus years
there become a world power and
technology and so to continue denying
that they are a state and once you
acknowledge they are a state that they
do have their own laws they have their
own leadership they get to pick where
their capital is we know country gets to
say where another country's got to put
their capital if it's an independent
country they pick their own CAPA
Israel has always said it was Jerusalem
that dates back to well first appears in
the Bible in the days of Abraham when
Melchizedek who was the king of Salem
later known as Jerusalem
Abraham pays him tithes so the place
appears the neighbor ham offers Isaac on
Mount Moriah which is a suburb of
Jerusalem and that's where the temple
was built and that of course David chose
this city that the Jebusites had
occupied Jerusalem and by the way
Jerusalem means city of peace that's
where you get Shalom he chosen is the
capital you know way back in thousand BC
and so the Jews of whenever they came
back even from babylonian captivity at
once again was a capital of Judea so
there was never a question for the Jews
when they were you know given permission
to reestablish their state that their
capital would be Jerusalem so but that's
just you know it's been hotly contested
by some of the Arab world that did not
like the way that the Israelis were
reintroduced into the region and I just
think you know we had to finally come to
the place where we admit it now some are
gonna say oh this is this is the
beginning of the end now because now
that they're declared the capital
there's gonna be an event and someone's
going to blow up the Dome of the rock
and the Jews are gonna rebuild the Third
Temple and the Antichrist will sit I
don't think that's the next thing to
happen
I do think yeah I go ahead you want to
say something so--but this you know it
seems to me like is the fulfillment of
prophecy the prophecy that it probably
closely fulfills is where it says in
pastor Ross's at Luke where it says
Jerusalem will be trodden down by the
Gentiles until the times of the Gentiles
be fulfilled so yeah that is one
specific prophecy talks about Jerusalem
being trodden to the Gentile some
believe that was fulfilled in 1948 when
they they got the Promised Land back
some are probably going to point to
Trump's announcement others pointed to
the Congressional see Trump just finally
recognized what Congress voted oh it may
have been at George Bush first year yeah
it's been several years when it was
first voted but and what's that verse
Luke chapter 21 verse 24 yeah I'll just
read it here for those who might not
have their Bibles handy it says and they
shall fall by the edge of the sword it's
talking about a time of persecution for
the followers of God's people and be led
away into captivity to all nations and
Jerusalem will be trampled by Gentiles
until the times of the Gentiles are
fulfilled
so that prophecy is gonna probably get a
lot of press in the next few weeks is my
guess but I would be I'd be careful
about saying that means that now the
Israelis are gonna bulldoze the Dome of
the rock and rebuild the temple I don't
think that's gonna happen there is a
prophecy about the Antichrist sitting in
the temple of God showing himself he is
God and I think that second
Thessalonians pastor Ross chapter 2 if
I'm not mistaken that temple that's
spoken of there is where Christ said
destroy this temple made with hands in
three days I'll raise it up he spoke of
his body the church is called the body
of Christ and so the Anti Christ sits
over the body of Christ showing himself
that He is God I don't think that's a
jesus walked away from the temple he
said your house has left you desolate
there's no need for the Jews to rebuild
the temple there's no plans in the
government for them to rebuild it and a
lot of that is kind of myths among some
evangelicals that was second
Thessalonians chapter 2 verse 4 yeah now
I've got a book I'd like to send you for
free it's a it's a sermon booklet that
talks about spiritual Jews spiritual
Israel and it it goes through some of
these prophecies and I think you'll
really be blessed it fits right in the
bullseye of your question would you like
a free copy of that I would and just so
you know I'm Don Mackintosh there's a
little brother oh good mr. I met your
son it was a director of my daughter's
production Oh oh good on the roof well
good for you then I'm glad you were able
to meet Steven we just had dinner with
him last night
thank you so
and we appreciate your call and we'll
we'll send regards to done it we'll be
sure and send you that free book yes
just call our resource phone line it's
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven you can ask for the book
called what is it called pastored a
spiritual is respira later all that's
right we'll be able to send this to you
Doug or anybody who calls and asks the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
you asked for the book called spiritual
Israel if you have a Bible question our
phone line here to the studio is 800
four six three seven two nine seven we
have Vito listening from Arizona Peter
welcome to the program gentlemen it's a
pleasure to chat with you likewise thank
you very much first-time caller at that
so you basically addressed an answer to
a partial question I had with the
previous caller so therefore I'm not
gonna argue with you or debating with
that question may I change question sure
yeah thank you all right so we're not
gonna belabor that point then you
brought up before you brought up don't
use a deck so I want a book of Hebrews
and I'm paraphrasing I'm driving and I
apologize Jesus was in the order of the
priestly line of Melchizedek
I've always wrestled with that what is
your take on that who was Melchizedek
especially the priest of Salem which
means teach right
yeah Melchizedek was the
Salem the similar word the same root as
Shalom in Hebrew which means peace je
rue means Cydia anyway it wasn't a city
back then it was probably more of a
district and he was the king of the area
but Melchizedek is sort of an enigmatic
character in the Bible in that as Paul
says he's without beginning her end
meaning there's no genealogy given for
him we don't know what people he was
from he evidently worshipped the Most
High God and his relationship with God
was so pure that even Abraham brought
him tithes after winning a battle
Abraham chose to go out of his way and
stop there and pay tithe to this man and
it says Melchizedek brought out bread
and wine to Abraham and his soldiers
and his name milk ml King means King Z
Dec I think means righteousness and I
could be getting the suffix and the
prefix mixed up there but it means king
of righteousness he is a type of Christ
so he brings forth bread and wine Jesus
seals a covenant with bread wine it says
he was a king jesus is our king it says
he's a priest jesus is our high priest
king of Salem Jesus is the king priest
of the New Jerusalem and he's one that
Abraham actually felt was great and he
paid tithes to him and one more thought
on that and the pastor also has a
thought I'd it's not in the Bible but I
think it's in Josephus writing that he
speculates that Melchizedek was actually
Shem who was one of the sons of Noah who
was still alive you know if you look at
the genealogy the son Shem was still
alive when this battle took place some
have speculated he can't prove it that
Shem when he saw that they were given
over to paganism he heard how God had
called Abraham to worship the true God
in this new land that he and his family
came and the only one who would be
greater than Abraham would be this
survivor from the end of the Louvre
Ian's world which was Shem so you know
it's hard to disprove that it makes
sense but you can't prove it either you
know it's interesting the the whole idea
of that appearing in Hebrews Paul uses
Melchizedek as an argument to show to
prove that Christ's priesthood is
superior to the priesthood of believers
because Jesus didn't come through the
tribe of Levi came through the tribe of
Judah and so in Hebrews Paul spends
quite a bit of time explaining that
Melchizedek is a type of Christ and that
Christ's priesthood is superior to that
of the Levitical priesthood because
Abraham gave a tithes to Melchizedek so
it's kind of an interesting argument
that he uses and that's why you find in
the New Testament Paul uses it to help
establish Christ's priesthood yeah it's
interesting that Paul does that here he
says Levi were still in the loins of
Abraham tired yeah yeah I hope that
helps a little bit we appreciate your
call you still don't appreciate the
attention thank you so much God bless
and happy merry Christmas to you all
likewise thanks so much next follies
James listening from New Jersey James
welcome to the program doing good thanks
for calling okay here's my question on
the book of Acts I'm asking you a lesson
on the book crack and I do not believe
in what you know Pentecostals and they
do understand by the gifts of Tom this
unknown language so I just want to know
what is your take on that well you and I
are probably in agreement I think that
the gift of tongues in acts is a
fulfillment of a prophecy Jesus makes in
mark 16 Jesus said you know I'm sending
you into all the world they were bright
but mostly uneducated fishermen and he
said I'm gonna supernaturally give you
the ability to speak in other tongues
for the purpose of spreading the gospel
what that means is on the day of
Pentecost there were devoted Jews from
all over the Roman Empire at least 16
different language groups God
supernaturally filled those apostles and
the people in the upper room there was
more than just the apostles with the
spirit and they were able to preach in
everything from Peruvian to Egyptian to
Latin all these languages that had were
represented there in the key in
Jerusalem those believing Jews then took
the gospel that they heard from the
Apostles they understood the miracle
that they were now speaking perfectly in
their languages they took the gospel
back to their native countries that's
the gift of tongues there's three
examples of tongue is in the New
Testament they're all in the book of
Acts acts 2 acts 10 acts 19 all three
times when they spoke in tongues there
are two or three language groups present
so someone recognized they're speaking
in a language that I know but they
didn't know it before and so it was for
the purpose of sharing the gospel they
were not just jabbering in a language
nobody knew and there's you know Jesus
never did that
and he was filled with the holy spirit
so we've got to be very careful about
making a doctrine where God doesn't put
a doctrine now we do have a free book on
this subject that we'll be happy to send
you and if you're wanting to teach a
class on this I tell you what you can
download this book for free and it's
simply called understanding tongues go
to the amazing facts website it's
amazing facts not Ord we will both send
you the book and you can download it for
free if you need it right away to teach
again just call our resource phone line
it's 883 five six seven four seven you
can ask for the book called
understanding tongues very important
subject I think you'll enjoy reading and
studying that just call and ask it's
free eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven and again you can ask
for the book called understanding titles
if friends we're just gonna take a brief
break and we do still have some lines
open so if you'd like to get your Bible
question on we see those of you who are
standing by we're gonna get to your
calls thank you for your patience just
give us a call 800 god says eight
hundred four six three seven two ninety
seven and if you're sitting there at
your computer you may want to click on
amazing facts dot o-r-g just type that
into Google or something you can go
online and donate to keep us on the air
we'll be right back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore calm
in six days God created the heavens and
the earth for thousands of years man has
worshiped God on the seventh day of the
week now each week millions of people
worship on the first day what happened
why did God create a day of rest it
doesn't really matter what day we
worship who was behind this great shift
discover the truth behind God's law and
how it was changed visit Sabbath truth
com can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G every Bible question you
have answered moves you one step closer
to the fullness of God's will for your
life so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call
[Music]
we are back and we are live and we want
to welcome any that have joined us in
route this is Bible answers live and you
know we had some questions tonight about
our is there a prophetic meaning to
President Trump just officially
recognizing why he wasn't the one who
really came up with the idea but he's
the president finally said let's
recognize it will move our embassy there
Jerusalem as the capital of Israel and
folks are wondering what does this mean
in the scope of prophecy and and you
might have a lot of questions about
prophecy I read an amazing testimony
tonight as someone that ran into the
amazing facts websites that deal with
prophecy and they said they're thanking
the Lord God Almighty that's a quote
they said they learned so much in just a
few days of looking at the information
there then they learned all their lives
on their own and if you would like to
see a tremendous website for Bible
prophecy you can remember this Bible
prophecy truth you type in Bible
prophecy truth to Google or Yahoo or
what are the other chrome or Microsoft
edge all your movies being and it'll any
of those it'll take you there to the
website it's Bible prophecy truth com
or.org and you'll see it talks about
angels mark of the bees Israel and
prophecy who is the Antichrist and just
all kinds of very interesting prophecy
subjects and gets deeper and deeper
Bible prophecy truth I am Doug Batchelor
my name is John Ross and we gonna go to
the phone lines we do have looks like
two lines open friends so if you want to
call in good time to pick up your phone
give us a call 800 four six three seven
two nine seven eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven
we've got Henry listening from New York
Henry welcome to the program yes how are
you guys with my question is if Adam and
Eve didn't sin was in the Garden of Eden
with them well the Garden of Eden was a
specific territory that probably would
not hold the whole human race it would
have been like Central Park of the world
because it says the Lord God plan
to the garden so it was a garden that
God planted if you can imagine that so a
lot of the world though beautiful it was
untamed adam was to go forth
he and his posterity and he was to
subdue the earth and so Adam the first
man was really a gardener he was to
dress and to keep the garden and as they
went forth from the garden they were to
explore and subdue the earth it probably
had so many wonderful things that were
lost after the flood we don't know about
but I'm sure as their offspring spread
around the planet they would have maybe
gathered at the Garden of Eden after
Adam and Eve were evicted from the
Garden of Eden between that time in the
flood they used to bring their
sacrifices to the gates of the garden
where God had brought he had put a I
think the word is a Seraphim a flaming
fire to guard the way so there was
something sacred about the garden and
that was yeah I don't think everybody
would have all congregated there at one
time right yeah the world would have
been perfect there would have been no
sin we would have been in the garden
with them and so yeah it would have been
beautiful matter of fact you know we've
got a book go ahead you're gonna say it
no I was just gonna mention we do have a
book that talks about the earth made new
and sort of even restored and it's got
an interesting name maybe it's the old
name I can't remember that colossal city
in space but we might have changed that
well the tree of life is the Garden of
Eden is in that city when it comes down
so that's that's the you can just ask
for that study guide and we'll be happy
to send it to anybody who calls and asks
it's all about heaven at colossal city
in space the number to call is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven just call that number and ask for
the study guide on heaven and we'll be
able to send that to anybody who calls
and yes Henry we can be in that city and
we can be in that garden you'll see it
firsthand if Jesus is first place in
your life absolutely
next Holies Marjorie from Michigan ma
Julia welcome to the program
thank you it's good to hear your voices
characters I'm having trouble getting my
words out but I will do my best and with
God's help maybe I couldn't oh no
problem you just relax were semi-normal
doctor said I was gonna be a backwards
baby we'll go figure anyway I have to
things went first of all when I was a
little girl I we had a crush that we put
under the tree every Christmas Eve mine
was older than me way older than me but
Joseph had gray hair in this manger now
I'm thinking if he had gray hair he was
a little bit older than Mary and had
been married before and had children and
was a widower and then when they were
spoken to by Gabriel Joseph took Mary
under his wing to protect her I think
that was according to Gabriel anyway
[Music]
no no late you're actually you're
actually right on well the the first
part anyway where Joseph was older than
Mary and here's the reasons we believe
that Jesus had brothers and sisters they
were probably older brothers and sisters
or half-brothers and sisters from Joseph
because when Jesus is dying on the cross
if the other brothers and sisters were
younger he would not have placed his
mother in the care of an apostle but he
places the care of his mother to John
well James his brother James was one of
the leaders in the church that's because
they were half-brothers Joseph probably
was married before his wife had died he
may have been older and another reason
we believe that is when Jesus begins his
ministry
Joseph's already passed away he never
appears again so we believe that Joseph
Joseph passed away sometimes between
Jesus twelfth birthday went Joseph's
last appears and when he began his
ministry at thirty we don't know when so
that's why most scholars believe that
that would be true now he did Mary Mary
after Jesus was born it says he didn't
know her until after he didn't know her
as a husband and wife until after Jesus
was born but we have every reason to
believe that they had normal marriage
relationship after that yeah so and you
said you had a second question oh yes
information about mcil Tzadik I maybe
it's just something I mean dreamt up in
the by from reading the Bible but I was
under the impression that God performed
miracles and that McKell Zadok was
brought down to administer to Abraham I
don't know how all went around but
that's what I thought I understood well
you're not alone there are a number of
people who believe that milk is acidic
was a what they call it christophany
that Jesus came to earth in the form of
a man others believe it was the Holy
Spirit I believe it was a real person
just because the context of for one
thing Abraham gives tithe to him and you
don't pay tithe to a phantom because you
know it's like when people leave these
gifts buy a statue of Buddha that they
you know the statue doesn't eat him so
yeah anyway I think that he was real
yeah absolutely and it's interesting
though the way Paul speaks of mouth is
it almost gives you that idea but when
you look at the context on what Paul is
trying to illustrate with the story of
Melchizedek no it was a real person
yeah yep hey thank you for your call our
next caller is Chris listening from
Indiana
Chris welcome to the program doing great
thanks for calling blasphemy question
but I kind of want to steer away from
that if that's okay
wait we all know that
last thing is an unforgivable sin but
you can sit down 20 people and get 20
different answers on that so you don't
want to get the twenty one answers and I
can toss my ring if I had the ring okay
go ahead you can in order to be forgiven
for since it can you get forgiven before
you come at the center do you have to
commit the sin to get forgiven well I
would never want to think that you say
lord I plan on stealing tomorrow can you
forgive me now because that's called
presumption presumptuous sin and that
that you know it's not the unpardonable
sin but that's definitely a sin in
itself that you would presume you know
during the Reformation there was quite a
stir about people who are selling
forgiveness for sin and you could buy
your forgiveness now and you could use
it sometime in the future you know
Martin older than the others yeah they
said you can't be you know buying
forgiveness that's not the way the
gospel works well because you have to
ask well first we others probably a lot
of people who commit suicide that will
not be forgiven because if the last act
of your life is hopelessness and
faithlessness and you then kind of
commit self murder that's not good and
so people who think I'm going to kill
myself and everything will get better
for most people that is just a big
mistake there may be a few folks who
because of mental illness and/or they're
going through such pain with their final
illness that they they you know do
something in in a moment
that's a rash we got to be careful not
to prejudge because you don't know
what's in a person's heart and you know
God is merciful so I don't think you can
say that every suicide is lost but
certainly the ones in the Bible that
committed suicide
it was pretty you know Judas hung
himself a hippo fella hung himself Saul
fell on his sword they were all in a
lost state at that point
so does that make sense well yes and no
I mean I know it's kind of a great area
I'm just little when I hear you know
there's only one unforgivable Sam but
yet I mean suicide would be technically
a second unforgivable Sam
yeah well it's but it's not called the
unpardonable sin it says the
unpardonable sin is blasphemy against
the Holy Spirit
you know I have a book on that I'll send
you a free copy it's a it's a regular
book and it's called beyond mercy talks
about what is the unpardonable sin and I
think that we address suicide in there
and I went through that very carefully
because it's a delicate subject number
to call for that is 800 yeah that number
to call for that free book is 883 five
six seven four seven that is the
resource phone line as for the book
called Beyond mercy and that deals with
the unpardonable sin and it's an
important read for anyone not just for
Kirk or are rather Chris but anyone can
call and ask for that my next caller is
a George listening from Montana George
you on the air hi yeah I have been very
confused in reading the Bible and
Commandments the commandment of thou
shalt not kill and it reverts back clean
to the Christian Wars and then it goes
into different parts of the Bible and
ecclesiastics it says chapter 3 there is
a time for peace and the time for war
there is a time for love and the time to
kill and then there's other places in
Romans and there's a one in the gospel I
believe it's according to John where you
sell your cloak and you buy a sword so
are you wondering if the Bible is
contradicting the Ten Commandments by
saying thou shalt not kill well no I'm
I'm questioning whether killing in the
name of the Lord
to keep the faith and alive
and then going into your country and
your family if that's correct or if it's
thou shalt not kill from a bug to a deer
alright well that's it I've heard
conflicting stories from hundreds of
people all right well tell you what let
me take a stab at that I think that the
misconception is coming from the typical
reading where it says thou shalt not
kill the Hebrew word there for kill is
actually murder and when Jesus quotes
the Ten Commandments in I think it's
mark chapter 10 he says thou shalt not
commit murder murder is significantly
different than pulling a weed he can
kill a weed or smashing a mosquito or if
chickens killed for Kentucky Fried
Chicken they're not all murdering murder
is the unlawful taking of innocent life
and so if a soldier goes out to defend
his country and he in the name of
defending his country needs to kill the
enemy he has not tried as a murderer and
so if you know police Paul talks about
that the government doesn't bear the
sword in vain if policemen need to take
up arms to protect the innocent then you
know if they're shooting a bank robber
and a shootout they're not called
murderers and so now you asked another
question about kind of questioning a
question where you were wondering about
where Jesus said let it take up a sword
let him sell his coat and get a sword
Christ was not suggesting that the
disciples take up arms because when
Peter pulled out a sword Christ had put
the sword away those that live by the
sword will die by the sword when Christ
talked about getting a sword he meant
the sword of the word he used to use
that term symbolically he said I came
not to send peace but a sword he meant
the sword of the word and the Word of
God is quick and powerful Hebrews 4
sharper than any two-edged sword so yeah
I don't believe Christians ought to be
taking up arms
is what he's saying that doesn't mean a
person can't be armed to protect their
home but anyway that's a deep question
and trying to think you know our study
on the law of God would probably be
helpful for this brother yes to receive
that study on the law of God the Ten
Commandments called written in stone
that I'm gonna call he's eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
you can ask for the study guide called
written in stone we'll be happy to send
it to anybody who calls and asks our
next caller that we have is Charles
listening from Kentucky Charles welcome
to the program thank you for having me
on thanks for waiting and your question
yes I have been studying some of the
Levitical laws and well I guess it's
kind of a somewhat awkward subject so
I'm not gonna be too I guess I'm fine
but um maybe it would be helpful if you
read verses 16 through 18 of chapter 15
to start with okay Leviticus I think I
know where you going
Leviticus chapter 15 you said and then
verses 16 through 18 and then I'll
explain the question after okay yeah if
a man has a personal omission then he'll
wash his body and be unclean until the
evening and any garment and any leather
on which is this permission it shall be
washed with water and unclean until the
evening and they'll bathe is that the
one you're wanting about and if he lies
with a woman right well right right
you're wondering do we is that something
we still practice today or what does
that mean well I'm kind of hoping for a
very thorough answer and the reason why
is because I don't know how far this has
to be taken because um now I guess let
me explain so what I believe in victory
over that kind of thing as far as you
know a person not putting any wicked
thing before their eyes and the kind of
thing and so I and I but even with that
victory it seems like that kind of thing
still happens even you know unwillingly
like to eat you know it's not that
anything intentional was done or
anything it's just that you wake up it
actually
says that yeah chances upon him by night
Moses refers to that mmm yeah so I guess
what I want to know and then it's like
okay so on a practical level how far do
you take that because like let's say you
sleep less than you sleep in the bed
that's where I organs would ya or let me
I think I know where you're going let me
let me just get to the answer here in
Bible time is because of course they did
not have some of the same sanitation
methods going through the wilderness
that we have today any a mission from
your body if it was spit if it was
anything else they were told you are our
nation of kings and priests you are to
be very clean and so to play it safe you
know whether they had a boil that was
using or anything it could be the
woman's monthly cycle they were
extremely careful about washing
everything and you know following those
sanitation laws when they finally did
enter into the promised land
then it says there wasn't one feeble
person among them I don't think that
Moses is saying that if a married couple
has normal relations that they need to
go then wash their sheets and they're
unclean until 24 hours go by you don't
see that being practiced in the New
Testament for one thing there's no other
reference to it but when they were a
nation come out of slavery God wanted
them to be very careful he actually says
that none of the diseases of the
Egyptians might come upon them and so
they had just some of the most stringent
sanitary laws they even had laws like if
you found a dead mouse in a clay pot you
were to break the pot but if it was in a
metal pot it could be washed and
salvaged and so it was all about being
extremely scrupulous and fastidious
about sanitation so I think I understand
the nature of what you're asking and and
yeah we can send you our lesson on God's
health laws that yeah God's free health
plan deals with some of these old tales
of the defenders yeah
to receive that give us a goal on our
resource number it's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven you can
answer the study guide coal gods free
health plan next cooler that we have is
Rob listening from Virginia raw welcome
to the program thank you so much for
accepting my call for some reason I've
just been seeing all of these YouTube
videos and about people who claim that
they've gone to hell and it's to
experience it and that there's the devil
and there's these demons that that
they're relishing this opportunity to
torture people who are condemned to hell
and and I thought that hell was set
aside for a place to torment the demons
and the devil but also I was confused
because they only can be one place at
one time and I imagine that there's
billions of people here on this earth
that they have to busy themselves to
distract them from from the grace of God
and they're in hell also relishing that
opportunity to torture people or can
they be in hell right now before the
Judgment Day
well I'm look can you help me out with
that I'm glad you asked first of all
I've run into some of those videos it
seems like people discovered that if you
say you had some remarkable experience
where you died on the operating table or
at a you know car wreck and then you
were revived and and you say oh you know
I I had a dream of heaven or I had a
dream of hell they're doing both you
know and they start to describe to
heaven one one lady si recently said I
went both places so I can bring back a
report and they are they conflict with
each other their experiences that they
have they don't even agree with each
other we don't want to ever base our
theology on somebody supposed dream
because there's all kinds of false
prophets out there Jesus said in the
last days
there'd be many false prophets and when
a perfect perfect person says I've had
this you know supernatural experience
for one thing the Bible is very clear
hell is not even burning now the Bible
says the wicked are not cast into hell
until the end of the world after the
judgment the judge
it hasn't happened because it says the
judgment is the last day and even Jesus
said in the parable of the wheat and the
tares he said the tares are the weeds
they're gathered in bundles and they're
bound and they're burned and he said so
will it be at the end of the world and
so the idea that God puts people in Hell
before the Judgment Day and then the
idea that they burn there throughout
endless ages well that's from the Dark
Ages that's not what the Bible teaches
the Bible says the wicked are burned
according to what they deserve and they
are consumed
they are devoured they burn up they
perish there's no more pain there all
things are made new so there's a lot of
misunderstandings on that subject so
when people come back and the idea that
the Devils are in charge of Hill the
Bible says the lake of fire is prepared
for Satan and his angels they are not in
charge that'd be like making the Fox in
charge of the chicken coop they're going
there so these people are just not
acquainted with the scriptures I don't
want to you know be so unkind and
question the sincerity but they're just
flat wrong and they're scaring folks now
I do think there's a heaven to be won
and a hell to be shunned
you know God does tell us that there's a
lake of fire and there is punishment for
the wicked and God does tell us there's
a wonderful reward for the redeemed but
while that might be a starting place for
somebody I'm a mature Christian serves
God because we love God not just because
what's in it for us right otherwise you
don't think Christ is fire insurance yes
yes well you know I appreciate that you
accept my call here and I really believe
that the lake the hell was reserved for
Satan and the demons and that they would
not be in charge and happy having a
party no you can't trust any fear Christ
said everyone will be punished according
to what he deserves you could never
trust the devil to be fair and in
meeting out punishment and so now he's
going to be in there as the prime
subject so yeah
you know we have a study guide we have
two things I want to tell you about one
is there's a website you can look at
real quick it's free it's called
hell truth has great resources called
hell truth comm is that right pastor oz
yes and then we've got a study guide is
the devil in charge of Hell right down
the line with your question the number
to call for that is 883 five six seven
four seven you can ask to the study
guide called is the devil in charge of
Hell I think we have time for one more
caller
we've got Jerry listening from Oregon
Jerry we've got just a minute math okay
thank you very much I'll get right to my
point
pastors I've heard the SDA view and I've
heard pastor Doug mentioned many times
it during the thousand years after
Christ returns the earth is desolate but
now when I look in Revelation 20 verse 3
it talks about him being thrown into
limits as and he hurled him into the
abyss and shut it and sealed it over him
so that he would not mislead the
nation's anymore until a thousand years
were over now revelation 27 says that at
the end of the thousand years he he's
released to deceive the nation's so
getting back to if if he's thrown into
the abyss Allah will not deceive the
nation's why is it stated that way if
the nation's in fact aren't there well
the nation's aren't there because
they're dead when Christ comes all the
nations Gog and Magog that's a term for
the enemies of God's people or the
wicked in the Old Testament and they're
killed by the brightness of Christ's
coming
Satan has no one to tempt or manipulate
for a thousand years at the end of the
thousand years when the new jerusalem
descends from heaven Christ will call
all the wicked up for the second
resurrection and then they're judged got
a study guide on that you can read for
free and it's called a thousand years of
peace the number to get for that is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven after the study got a
thousand years of peace sorry we had to
rush you through that question he
listening friends thank you so much we
got a couple more announcements that are
very important but before Pastor Ross
and I close out this part of our study
we appreciate anything you could do to
help amazing fact stay on this
you're listening to just go to amazing
facts dot-com we'd love to hear from you
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
are you wondering what lies ahead in
human history landmarks of prophecy
offers clear answers to your most
pressing questions presented by pastor
Doug Batchelor landmarks of prophecy is
a video Bible study adventure designed
for today's audiences presenting the
landmark themes of the Bible in a
compelling way giving you knowledge to
face the future with confidence start
your ethnic Bible study adventure with
landmarks of prophecy today by calling
[Music]
877-709-7899 out top scholars and
theologians from around the country come
together to reveal the hidden history of
the book of Revelation with
powerful reenactments and incredible
visual effects this 95-minute
masterpiece brings to life the book of
Revelation like never before revelation
is no longer a mystery get your copy
today visit iTunes or AF bookstore com
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF AG 0 RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore comm which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]